みなさん、ここで高低アクセントを使って、このシリーズの高低アクセント日本語
の第2話へようこそ。
私は
あなたの日本語を音声で分析したので、あなたが日本語
を話す録音を聞いて、日本語の音声学を教える
日本人教師としての知識を活用します。
高低
アクセントと
高低アクセントピッチアクセントと発音私
はパトレオンでこれらを教えて
あなたの日本語をもう一度分析します私の
日本語は完璧にはほど遠いです、そして私
は過去にこれについて話しましたが、ええと、
私はあまりその道を行きたく
ないので ビデオに取り掛かった方がいいと思うので
、今日のレッスンの2回目の録音に進みます。
この
ビデオはカリカリからのものになるので
、カリの録音を見てみましょう。 今
[音楽]
日曜日
あなたは素晴らしいスタートを切っていますこれも
素晴らしいですあなたは素晴らしい品質
を持っているのであなたはかなり良いマイクのように見え
ますそしてあなたはサブタイトルを追加しました
私が話したいの
は複合規則なので、
ビデオの前半で大学のことを言った
ので、高低のことを言ったので、今すぐそれを見つけてみましょう。
表示さ
れますが、とにかくこのルールをカバー
します。あなたの場合は、
高低アクセントではなく、
イントネーション
であり、どのように曲がりくねっているようなものだと思い
ます。
話者の
意図や感情などを考慮に入れていないときに、個々の単語のアクセントが空白になっている場合を除いて、感情をスピーチにマッピングします
が、私がやろうとしているのは
、 私がカバーするつもりだっ
たのですが、これは大きな
ものです。
ほとんどの場合、
日本語の2つの名詞を
組み合わせる
と、
高低アクセントのパターンが低くなります。
これ
は
、日本語のアイスコーヒーという単語を単独で使用している場合、どういう意味
ですか？isaという単語は、ahに
アイスアイスアイス
のアクセントがあるため、アクセントが高くなり、
次に低くなりますが、 それをコーヒーの単語
のスタンドアロンの単語kohikokohiと組み合わせると、
彼は氷の
ように冷たくなります。私の
経験では、一部の高齢者は
実際にそれを氷のように冷たい熱と発音
しますが、ほとんどの若者は
アイスコールドヒートと聞いたことがあります
が、私が言いたいのは
、isipの元の高低アクセントが
正しく変化するため、単語の元の高低
アクセントが上書きされ
、ピッチが低くなり、次に高くなり、次に高くなるということです。
彼らが一緒に落ちるまでそれは高いままなので
、ここでもルールはあなた
が化合物の低高低パターンを聞きたいということですそしてあなた
がこれを聞き始めるとあなたはどこでもそれを聞き始めるでしょう
そして私が
これを最初に育てた理由 私が思うからです
ちなみにボストン大学のグレートスクールと言った
ので、単独
で単語または大学はダイゴです
それは低く始まり、
高くなり続けます
孤立はピッチ事故を受け
、複合体
の全体的なピッチアクセントパターン
は低高になります
低高低
したがって、アイスコヒまたはボストンと言っている
かどうかにかかわらず
、日本語の個々の名詞が組み合わされ
て複合語を作成する場合、ほとんどの場合、
低高低ページのアクセントパターンになり
ます。これを聞き始めると どこでも
それを聞き始めるでしょう。
私はちょっと
接線を外れて、
あなたが困っているようなことについて話しましたが、
それはピッチアクセントのこと
ではなく、あなたの場合はもっとumについてだと思います
抑揚とイントネーションなので
、日本語の個々の単語ではなく
、一般的な抑揚
パターン
は英語からのもののように聞こえますii
ネイティブの英語話者
は気だと思います 自分自身を日本語にマッピングする
ので、
ここで少し抽象的になり
ます。うーん、あなたは
自分の考えを明確に表現するのが本当に上手な
ので、一時停止することはありません。
これをすべて1つに
まとめて、単語
を組み合わせて文章を作成する方法をとるのは
本当に良いことです。これが
あなたの強みであることがわかります。
日本語に関しては、おそらく何
が起こる
かというと、あなたが日本語を勉強する方法は、あなたが教室で3年間勉強したと言ったと思います。
多分、あなたは教室で本当に一生懸命日本語を勉強し
たので、
日本語で文章を作る方法それ
は理にかなっていますそして
またあなたはこれをすべて1つのテイクで行いましたそれ
は本当に印象的
です
教室で外国人
が日本語を話そうとするのではなく、多くのネイティブスピーチを聞くことによるネイティブスピーチと一種の浸透を通して、あなたは日本語に存在する
高低アクセントパターンまたはピッチ行為
とパターンのより良い無意識の理解を得るでしょうが
また
、日本人
が感情を言葉にマッピングするさまざまな方法も、
高低アクセントと結びついて
います。自然にそれを行うには、高低アクセントを少し知っておく必要があるためです。
アクセントのある単語は少ない
ですが、あなたの特定の
状況では、前のビデオで
ハルサンに勧めたものとは逆のことができる
と思います。日本の映画を選んでください。
前のレッスンで話したように、アニメはしばしば存在するので、アニメではなく嘘のようではなく、実際の俳優がいる通常の映画を使用し
てください
ファンタジーの世界のようなもの
で、そこ
から文化的な知識を得ること
ができませんが、
netflixのテラスハウスのようなものや
、私が通常パトレオンで生徒に勧める映画の1つを
見ると、
ええと12人の日本人と呼ばれている
ので、ここに日本の名前を入れます
が、その映画は
あらゆる種類の日本の音声規則を学ぶのに素晴らしいです
、そしてその理由は
それが法廷ドラマであり
、映画全体が
内で行われるからです 部屋1つの部屋とすべての
俳優が
2時間まっすぐに話し
ているので、その映画では誰もアクセントで話し
ません。 確かに、しかし私
はその映画の女の子のキャラクターの一人が方言で話すと信じてい
ます、
そしてあなたが一種の方言で話すなら、あなたが一種の標準的な日本語を
学ぼうとしているならそれは理想的ではありません
あなたが拾った言葉と彼女
がその映画で言っていたことが原因ですが
、それ以外の場合は標準的な日本語で話すと
、日本の音が断片化されます。
私が個人的に最もお勧めするのは
人の親切な日本人です。
古い映画なので見つけるのは少し難しいですが
、最初から最後までノンストップのスピーチであり、
他のことをしている間にそれをバックグラウンドで繰り返すだけなら
歯を磨くとき
、宿題をするとき、
必要なことをするとき、部屋を掃除するとき、
本当に本当に遠くまで行く
ので、この時点でもっと入力が必要
だと思います。
本当に良いスタートを切った
ので、このビデオはおそらく十分な長さだと思うので、
ここで終わり
ます。日本語を訂正してほしい場合は、日本語
を話すビデオを送ってください。
ツイッターを使用している間は
、ドガンのツイッターで
ビデオを埋め込み、ビデオへのダウンロードリンクを含めます。
また、字幕を追加できる場合
は、今すぐ行か
なくてはなりません。
すぐにまた